I'm a tribe wife. I got married at 18.
My husband is the main breadwinner
and I'm pregnant with our first child.
What would I do if my husband were to die?
I've been asked this question a lot
and I thought it was high time I made an in depth series on it.
So welcome to the third part of my Emergency Protocol series.
Today I'm gonna walk you through exactly what I would do
if my husband were to die.
First, our families,
his and mine,
would come and help me sort out the funeral and the burial.
Some family would probably stay to help me with childcare.
Packing up my life here. I would sell the house,
this truck, most of our belongings.
Do something like an estate sale
and I would move in with my family
and put myself under my father's roof.
My family has a guest house and campers,
so I would have my own house on their property.
My parents and grandparents both live there,
so they would help with Jane
and it wouldn't be hard for me to continue to work while raising her.
I'm already making a full time income on social media.
But if that were not to work out for some reason,
I would probably go back to wedding photography.
However, I don't really see myself as having a lot of financial needs
because my family has already offered to provide for me financially.
If my husband were to Die.
And then as life goes on, I would be homeschooling our daughter Jane
and get involved in local church.
And eventually, I definitely do see myself remarrying.
Living the rest of my life alone
is not something that I have everyone to do.
So while it's something that's very hard to think about,
if my husband were to die,
I would like to get married again in the future
and have that father figure for our daughter
and have that companionship that marriage has to offer.
Let me know in the comments if you have any questions
to continue the series with.